hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to factorial I almost
forgot I wanted to say futuro for some
weird reason I know that's and it say hi
Bob
hey how's it going yeah so Bob and I are
back and I'm about to [ __ ] you late
everything because I just turned off I
don't know what to do now all right it's
okay just keep working on the science
where we're getting logistics in the
next level so we just need to upgrade
logistics and then we're going to be
moving forward with everything I lost
you feel lost I feel lost inside I do
why I don't know I just do well why do
you care
Oh tuck geez I I thought I was your
friend but I guess not crap this got off
to a somber start what the hell does it
matter to you anyway
what does anything matter in fact this
is all [ __ ] anyway
that's a [ __ ] illusion okay anyway
what I'm what I'm doing is I'm making a
line like this because this way I can
have in Surtur's moving the [ __ ] where
it needs to go in a line instead of
having to manually fill it up all the
time and then with three steam engine
it's gonna be a lot more power and then
everything can move with maximum
efficiency because what I wasn't
realizing is things were not moving at
maximum efficiency we were very much
under power oh yes very under power so
once we're maximum power like the the
the electric miners they'll work with
the power that you give them but they
won't work at maximum efficiency so you
got to make sure that it's a hundred
percent so this if you left-click on a
pole again now you'll see that
production and consumption are exactly
matched we still need more power high
hot tits damn it if you have put more
boilers on it I don't know how many
boilers you can match up to a steam
engine such you can put another boiler
on there probably pinchy yeah I can let
me see if there's gonna work I'm no idea
here's to be working ah but has power
gone up thank you thank you yeah it went
up a bit a little bit
I know it's still one point one that was
what it was before uh I don't know if
like there must be an upgrade like down
the road
we'll help it do that more we just put
another steam engine up you're right we
could and I will do that no me oh [ __ ]
ha ha I did it you did it you're the
best you're better than me you yet you
got enough
you got enough space there yeah okay so
everybody out there now that we got
enough power like I said everything's
gonna be working at maximum efficiency
and thusly we can have more production
asset II did not go up didn't go up what
with 400 that one's not connected to the
grid okay
oink and that should go up see it it did
not go up what Kenny's this is [ __ ]
how do we have production do you have to
wire them in a certain way or something
know that I need another pole that
should be oh I'm an idiot I only have
one offshore pump for four of these bars
I'm so I'm sorry everybody out there I'm
a huge idiot help me clear this forest
out a bit more
okeydoke yeah well I'm stuck stuck on
all the things actually it'd probably be
better to do it over there where you
were because okay that would be better
yeah why what was I even thinking of
course there's only one pump going to
four of these bastards well where's the
pump asking me yeah it's in the you you
see it I don't got no irons well there's
tons of ayran x' is like unlimited
amounts of Byron's so if I do this like
this and then have more of these suckers
running yeah if you have all the pumps
you need ah I'm good yes what the [ __ ]
what's in the way ah so this croc no
okay we're good okay so that should
allow us to nope nope no don't tell me
nope didn't do any you you are lying to
me if you're saying that didn't do
anything that had to have done something
to me they click on the pole then it
there's no way it couldn't have done
nothing it has to have done something
what I don't know I have no idea what
it's less power
now what the hell I am thoroughly peeved
this this doesn't make any sense
wonder what happens if I just only one
boiler per thing here I know this is
very boring for everyone out there know
what but I'm trying to think I'm not an
expert at the game yet by any capacity
okay so that's exactly the same
production elessedil what'd you do
nothing
those are defense you've ruined our turn
I got it I got it it's fine all right
are you sure no okay
yeah see each of these things should be
able to pump out 510 kilowatts so I'm
guessing that would be if they were
exactly in line with each other each
with their each individual offshore pump
so that's what I'm gonna do oh good
logistics got done nice Oh
so hopefully that'll give me the brain
power to be able to solve this but no
hopes really for that yeah let's not go
crazy you could have some faith in me
you know what he's time B night I mean
you can mark I'm confident that you can
do it one of these times when i insult
myself I just want to hear no mark no
you you're trying really hard you know
you're guiding us through this
experience it's gonna be it's gonna be
good you'll be happy you are trying so
hard mark you're you can do it God now
I'm sadder than I ever was before thank
you all right hopefully we don't get
attacked right now because [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm
gonna give this okay actually whatever
it's electric also uh no actually those
turrets if laser turrets they would be
electric but those actually runs are
fully functional turrets man yeah
they are super cool so I'm just gonna
watch and see what's going on here okay
so what I've got going on here is move
please
Oh what we've got here is I've got each
individual pump is going to go to its
own destination and then they're each
going to provide power to the individual
boiler
next to these bad boys and then these
are going to go like that and then
actually I'm going to make pipe two
grounds because pipe two grounds allow
me to put things underground
oh no don't trap me in there and too
stupid I'm too stupid to figure this out
you got it Bob though it's good okay so
that did nothing [ __ ] didn't work okay
never mind I'm not gonna do that because
it's stupid and I actually didn't like
it and I didn't want to do it in the
first place okay so he just just set
them all up and if you could if you
could put coal in them I'm not they're
all full of coal okay thank you I've got
way more cool than I ever need I haven't
got any poles though so I got out of
poles don't worry I got it covered
okay so we got one yeah I don't
understand how I make it more powerful
and I feel like the solution is not as
complicated as it seems like it might be
for us it's cool
link okay so now if we click on the pole
it's going up up up up up up up up up
and it's less than it was before failure
but I can't do it up and the failure I
just can't do it I can't give you yeah
it's just the way it's impossible okay I
know what I know what to do it's it's a
it's a problem of boilers I need more
boilers is what I'm saying mm-hmm
yeah so what we're gonna do so we're
gonna put more boilers I have so much
confidence in you mark thank you Bob oh
I actually need to be right back so you
just go thinking about that Oh ed um
I'll be back y'all right do we have more
power uh no the problem is I don't know
um I'm gonna
redo all of that one Mota me oh there
was stone here hidden out you got damn
it look there's like two stone here oh
let's have to learn well how would we
have known it was buried under an entire
forest least I'm getting plenty of wood
you know all the good that I can do with
my wood in this game god dammit stop
there's so many goddamn trees I can't
even click on the goddamn right one
alright let's see it went up at all with
two more of these [ __ ] on me okay
it did not why is it not that doesn't
make any sense
that's impossible do we need to separate
the grids I did how what it we what if
we separate the grids so that like uh
gosh I don't know like what if we
separate this off and then connect down
this way yeah and so these guys are
powered only by that one grid uh-huh
okay a B let's see oh my gosh black
whatever I just did made it so angry
it's really thinking about really sorry
video game oh god what have you done
okay there we go we're back nope we're
not okay there we are we're we're
chugging along it's it's really thinking
about it
Carolee I just found a horrible and I'm
really sorry
oh yeah I'm just struggling to pick up
call it's like the framerate hasn't
dropped it all it's literally the server
is just like oh god why are you doing
this
understand okay alright so there's
obviously something that's stopping us
from it's like I even like hover over a
minute says like the performance is
super low for each of these maybe the
problem is like the double boiler system
maybe the double boiler is just
completely wrong maybe it just needs to
be one boiler pearl yeah cuz I separated
I think I separated the grids oh now
they're not separate Oh God
it doesn't matter you have no adverse
dude man here comes depressed Bob again
hmm it's just it's all solid why it's
all lie nothing even nothing oh uh uh
you okay down there yeah she's jumping
around a little bit okay yeah I think
it'll smoke out eventually but I don't
know if we're really gonna have the
efficiency I just don't know if that's
meant to happen there there we can up
the efficiency but we can up the power
there has to be weighed up the power
this doesn't mix in all my games when I
was playing by myself this worked like
it did he just did this doesn't make any
sense
all right I'm going to break everything
down again and I'm gonna try one more
time and this is gonna work
I'm gonna do what I do literally the
thing that I was doing in the other oh
okay there we go I'm gonna do literally
the thing that I was thinking about in
the other in my other playthrough where
I played for hours and I had lots of
power and everything was fine
hmm this one and everything was just
swimming swimmingly swimming along yes I
don't want the end oh oh god no no I
wish ah yeah but I think is gonna do it
because they're all the part off the
thing okay yeah oh my god all the power
plants actually yes hopefully this will
solve all our problems
okay so what I recall from what I was
doing before is I had basically I had
one pump per two machines and I had them
splayed out on either side as such as
this likes and like such as and like
such as this like that alright so and
then I have the offshore pump like right
such as that we move this in way I need
to figure out where this is gonna land
before I figure anything else out but
then I just had like a boiler on the on
the blood ends of each of these so it
went a little like
[ __ ] like that and then I had a split in
between the two hmm and so these should
let's just see how much power this
produces I know
and this produces look at that that's
the power we were working with before
right yeah yeah and actually that comes
consumption is slightly less than that
yeah everything powered right now
yeah but the consumption could be higher
if we had more power so I'm going to do
this exact set up again elsewhere and
it's going to be good
in theory why not in theory everything
is beautiful in theory absolutely
chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga tickets
Stevenage I can check that and thusly
like this thus and I put I put coal in
the boiler so thank you thank you I say
I put cool in the boilers cuz that's not
the right word I'll allow it
okay and there we go okay and now the
power is not up wait wait wait mark wait
hang on okay so the production is that
the exact same is the consumption right
yeah but there's a lot more of the
production bar that's not filled in
which means that the consumption is
eating everything that it needs and
we're only using one third of our
current cap capacity on the production
right yeah so our production is actually
about 2,100 kilowatts yeah because yeah
so we are making more power this time
yeah so we may have been making more
power before and just been too stupid to
realize I think you're right I think
this has just been [ __ ] with us I
think we just don't know how to read
grabs oh it's only but oh oh
that is right ah I'm so stupid oh my god
well [ __ ] okay I can't I just can't
thank you thank you thank you Bob you
helped us happen incredibly I'm such a
tit and Matta does not look good so we
just spent an entire episode trying to
figure out what the hell we were doing
with that okay well um so I mean oh yeah
what we figured it out in the end I
think what's important is that we
figured it out yeah but what else is
important I think we need to give the
people watching like five more minutes
of productive time which so we have we
and so so so so so so we have logistics
yes what the hell do we do with
logistics well yeah
so logistics is basically in your
logistics crafting tab we got what are
called underground belts and splitters
when you have incoming cargo a splitter
will spread it on to two different
conveyor belts one to one so if you have
like the iron and the coal on this line
it'll split it into two different lines
and then those will go in different
directions same with the the copper and
stuff but that's for more intricate
builds the more interesting thing is we
have fast inserters and long-handled in
Surtur's so they will go distances that
they can drop things off from far away
or close so those will help out in
making bigger and more complicated
routes but before we do that we need to
finish up electronics in them we need
advance material processing so right now
we're doing really well on this front
but the next steps in production are
making what are called assembly loops
and this is I'll just generally make
what I call an assembly loop and you'll
judge and see if it's actual
anything worth bragging about which
admittedly it probably won't be because
it's a horrible design and no one should
be proud of it
oh we're gonna try it so the basic of an
assembly loop is these assembly machines
will make things with two parts we I
would like to have the next level up
which makes things with three parts and
I'm actually going to replace this with
a fast inserter as soon as these
assembly machines are done actually you
can do that can you replace the instead
of having two of these things and that's
actually pretty cool with the looping
system there but can you replace them
with the blue ones which are called fast
inserters and they move wicked fast and
you'll replace the overflow drivers yeah
I'll be over
yeah the overflow ok yeah I can do that
okay do I need to on the end like I have
already or uh just look at one and
you'll see what it looks like okay yeah
like on the steel parts are actually the
copper party or the coal part here yeah
yeah see how fast that goes yeah oh my
god yeah so he moves bitchin fast and I
think that's actually gonna be enough to
overflow all of it so he should be good
that is fantastic
I know right you see they do produce or
consume a little more power but they're
way better for a wiggly waggly one all
right yeah so now that we got power and
now that we got this and now that I have
assembly machines so basically an
assembly loop is you put four in a
curtain no wait you put four and a
square like that and then you take
conveyor belts to move them around each
other so you basically have what looks
like this not like that what looks like
this whoops [ __ ] sorry little drunk like
this egg that's like this and oh ma I
ran out of conveyors [ __ ] cutting I got
I got okay
like that's hang out I ran out of
conveyors dammit
I got it yeah like that okay okay so now
you have those and what we're gonna do
is I'm gonna make a science loop so
whether it's one thing making gears and
that just needs steel and then there's
the rest that are making science
literally just the red science packs and
this is very basic so we need an input
and that comes from inserters moving
things in so we need uh what what we
need are two chests because we need the
thing that this thing needs is copper
and it needs steel plates Ryan well I
have two chests okay where should I put
them like down here yeah just put it to
away so that we can have in Surtur's
putting them in there that yeah so then
we have inserted pointing in the inward
direction we okay the pole going right
there oh I was gonna okay I got this
cool and then we put copper in one and I
got a whole bunch of stuff on me so
copper in one and then iron in the other
so that one is copper and that one has
iron so when we put in more in Surtur's
not burner in Searchers why do I have
burner inserters just a shoot but I
should put inserters in two of
everything yes in going inwards and I'll
put the power poles okay
and then also going outwards okay it'll
look so I need just Oliphant I'm not
completely out of stuff I got one more I
got I got it
I got so in and then out so the out ones
put it on the far side of the loop so
that all the output is on the far side
and then the in ones will just keep the
materials on the inside so that there's
always like copper and steel as needed
oh so as you can see three of them are
producing science and they will output
science
in a jiffy as soon as it starts
producing the first one and there see on
the belt
you got one science so now we just need
a splitter to get the science off of
that belt onto its own collection built
ah not quite we could we just we just
finished making electronics which has a
smart inserter so if you make a smart
inserter yes I will make one yeah and
then I will place that and then I will
also make a chest to put some ass
berries I have figuring things out
inside my brain you're doing great Bob
you're doing great inside that eight
year old brain it's cool so put the
smart and trigger down and then there
red science
yes exactly I'm all about that [ __ ] okay
and then I'll just power it okay the
power mightily this ugly on your side so
I think that's my fault
okay so this is what you do this is all
you need to do because now you have a
constant supply so long as you keep the
chest filled that's [ __ ] amazing
yeah so it's a very compact little
design that's gonna produce all the red
science that we could possibly need make
sense amazing cool mark it's amazing
thank you I was just looking for self
affirmation cuz I am honestly pretty
stoked about this though like yeah it's
very much just gonna do itself its gonna
do its own business genes right now yeah
but cool right so you just keep building
assembly loops like that or better
design their assembly loops it's just
what I figured out could be made and the
whole game is freezing up but it's just
what I figured out could be made it's
really cool
every but this is just one solution to
the problem in this game you can make
any solution to the problem that you
want so literally whatever your
imagination you can do this with
splitters underground conveyor belts you
have things going all over the place it
could be I think we're going to run into
the problem of the belt eventually
filling up with copper yes it will do
that and the problem with that one is uh
that's where the the that's why I said
this is shitty this is a terrible design
I got I got literally the worst yeah
okay ah speed up the iron so hopefully
at least it fills in any open gaps that
exist
with iron and then keeps the balance and
that's smart because it'll do it before
the copper gets in there mm-hmm
so it'll fill as many iron spots up as
it can yeah okay but anyway this is all
the time we have for this episode thank
you everybody so much for watching thank
you Bob for joining me for this one yeah
yeah and hopefully you guys are enjoying
it home so thanks again and as always
we'll see you in the next video bye-bye
spouting splashing soaking innards in
just invoking naeli never stops of
coking smokeless or whatever that may be
okay that that didn't work